Amazon have ordered an audit that's
quite hard to say of every single
project they have movie TV series
anything regardless of what point in
production it is they want to know if
there's anything they could cancel
welcome to Sidetrack here Sci-Fi TV and
move your Channel
[Music]
foreign
now as soon as the strike was announced
we kind of expected this and according
to a source that I have that works
doesn't work for MGM anymore but works
for quite a large talent agency He
suggests that actually every studio will
be doing this but my best sources are
MGM and Amazon so they're the people
who've told me this is actually
happening there but we can assume Disney
Universal Paramount etc etc are doing
exactly the same thing now the source
said to me that this is basically an
audit we actually called it something
else but it's an audit for the sake of
what we're talking about management at
the big studios are going to look at
every single project that's currently in
development or actually even filming
they are going to ask the creators of
those projects to kind of Almost Do a
pitch to talk about where they're at
what their spending is like what their
plan is following the strike ending and
basically are there any problems that
the strike is throwing up the writers
and the actors who desperately need our
support so please get on Twitter get on
other social media follow the writers
the actors Etc that you love follow the
producers of the TV shows that you love
and show them your support but basically
when the strike ends these shows won't
just get started straight away some
shows won't have a massive problem
because they're set within Studios on
sound stages there's those same stages
are still there they can keep them
maintained while the strike is going on
and they're like basically locked down
and they can just get straight back in
all they have to do is get the food
trucks back get the lighting on and
crack on but some shows that have maybe
filming Outdoors filming on locations
Etc might not find it so easy what
happens if you've been filming on
location at a building somewhere but
then when the strike is done it's no
longer available what do you do well
Amazon will be looking at and they'll be
saying what will you do and if the
creators can't give them a decent answer
it may just mean that the show gets
canceled
now Amazon will be looking to save a
little bit of money Disney
Etc they're all going to be looking to
save some money and they're also
potentially going to be looking to
cancel a few shows from Project leaders
actors Etc that have pissed them off
during the strike now I'm hoping that
isn't the case but I mean Jenny staven
and dial the gate was talking about just
a few days ago that actually retribution
is a tool that these people are more
than willing to use and actually we may
see a few projects get canceled just
because the executives don't like what
the Creator's writers actors have done
with themselves during the strike
there's also a point that Executives sat
around thinking twiddling their thumbs
is not a good idea and all of a sudden
you get teams of people having new
marvelous ideas and those new marvelous
ideas might be to cancel the show you
love
all of these are very very real threats
and now we know these audits have
started I can't help but be concerned
now
could this affect Stargate
well yes of course it could my sources
told me a couple of times now that
basically you've got to think of this as
a clean slate nothing that we know up
till this point is true anymore
it could mean that they completely
change their plans it could mean that
Executives actually decide that maybe
they're not going to push forward to
Stargate at the moment at all now I
actually don't think that's a major risk
I think shows that are already up and
running are more at risk shows that
maybe you've had four or five seasons
they're at risk because creators might
go you know what when we come back from
this we need to announce something big
we need to announce something new and
maybe a fifth season of whatever show
that it's been doing okay maybe it's
popular isn't going to give us the
impact we need
but announcing something new now that
would be good so I actually think
Stargate will come under that category
of shows or movies that they desperately
will want to announce because it's
exciting it's new it'll get clicks it'll
get people like me talking about it
etc etc if I did a video at the end of
the day of saying you know season five
of blah blah blah has been announced it
won't get many views but when I do a
video saying the Stargate has finally
been announced it will get a lot of
views
and that's basically why Amazon would do
it
so that is only my opinion but I feel
the Stargate is safe because of that
reason but we have to accept that a lot
of other projects aren't and that
managers
people that aren't really creative types
are going to be spending their time over
the next few weeks and potentially
months looking at every project they've
got up and running thinking about every
dollar pound Yen whatever that they've
got invested and thinking about whether
it is worth spending the money to carry
on those projects
or even whether it's even practical to
continue those projects
this is a period that is very concerning
and the longer the strike goes on the
more stuff will get the cup so please
again get out there show your support
for the projects you love the most TV
shows movies franchises whatever
follow the actors follow the writers
follow the directors
they need your help right now we need to
make sure that we are shouting that we
want these things to happen Social Media
Matters your voice matters stuff
trending on Twitter matters
and the more you we do it the louder we
shout the more the studios will listen
and the more the studios will
potentially be willing to actually give
the actors and the writers a deal that's
fair
so get out there and make your voices
heard
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps essentially
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you go to patreon.com forward
Sidetrack where you get to see most of
our new videos first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel you get to see them
without the adverts you get a free gift
too
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
[Music]